Depending on what part of your body needs to be x-rayed,...
...you might have to put on a hospital gown.
You'll also need to take off all jewelry, watches and glasses.
Metal gets in the way of taking a clear picture.
The x-ray technician, tech for short, takes you to the room with the x-ray machine...
...and a table to sit on, lie on or stand beside.
Think of the x-ray machine as a giant camera.
The tech will help you get into the best position for the x-ray.
You can help by trying to hold very still.
Then the tech will move to a little room nearby,...
...where she'll press the button to take the x-ray.
Here we go.
Stay still.
This usually is very quick.
You'll probably hear a clicking or buzzing sound as the picture is being snapped.
The tech will tell you when it's okay to move.
Okay.
Picture's done.
When it's all done, you can get dressed.